it was an event probably unprecedented
in the history of the german finance
ministry a procession through the
corridors of power to open the sound of
luxembourg artist musician Catrin lauren
is playing a traditional song from her
native country kappa jesus oh no he
knows i chose the sun arena C&R that's
what we call a procession piece for
dundee gone through the luxembourg army
band marches to it to celebrate the
national holiday it's not fair tax but
this is different from the national
anthem i adapted it for guitar and with
less ponce than the version played by
bands nagato visa fees and the capella
dispute the sound of luxembourg in this
case isn't upbeat won the country
presents the cream of its jazz scene
with acts including the mock scene
vendor quartet and the jeff hair
corporation
as a digestion looks more than the exact
time affected the jazz scene in
Luxembourg is very small compared to
Berlin or cologne of course DOM is the
silent Guinea rats units but what's
interesting is how professional the new
generation is why not new for him that's
gaps fire it's not nice to davia hot new
its way out of London phone we're just a
two-hour car drive for brussels cologne
in the netherlands and just two hours by
train from Paris size and most students
go abroad to study in the good thing is
mais most do come back and become
established in Luxembourg condition
luxembourg keep are doing the Goethe
hunt for there are a good handful who
have reached a really high level of
skill and ability salgaocar capacitating
also able to skills luxembourg presents
some of its very best musicians like the
contemporary classical sounds of the
ensemble noise Watchers unlimited the
sound of Europe also features panel
discussions this time again hosted by
Peter Lim Borg DW director-general
German Finance Minister Wolfgang
schäuble always attends yo look towards
the special guests this year is his
Luxembourgish counterpart Pia gramineae
Vulcan chocolate is an avid jazz fan
this about the art from testes see mr
gandhi this is the kind of chairs that i
really like a zoo I didn't go looking
for it yeah it's up me open it reminds
me of years gone by in my life does he
said the aim of our series of events
what we're trying to achieve is for
those who come to these events to have
the feeling afterwards that they're a
little more familiar with the country we
have presented its Cynthia B sin foto de
bday blunt the Duchy of Luxembourg is
one of the smallest members of the
European Union it's home to wonder
600,000 people almost fifty percent of
than non-natives the country has three
official languages German and French
bloomers dog and luxembourgish in which
songwriter sarish tone r performs pick
up fulcrum finish Kissin much shopping
under start
the Parkland pants police turn on Adams
tire had this uneasy tinnitus of Lakshmi
it's rare to hear anyone in the popular
music scene singing Luxembourgish Fosse
its field of core but now we're
increasingly hearing it in rap and
hip-hop four examples yes no status of
common vida de luxe muggers paha as it's
true it's lovely to see but we really
have very few singer-songwriters Lucas
yezir vinegar and in the rock scene it's
almost all in English their signals
honest in a the sound of Europe a
musical manifestation of diversity in
unity next year it will feature the
Netherlands and Slovakia ah that's good
man